Friend of mine was just diagnosed with celiac, oh ties right into this, what would you say are the most important things to do beyond this eating a gluten-free diet and can it be healed?
Well, it partly depends on how bad the celiac disease is.
The celiac disease is diagnosed through a biopsy, the intestinal wall, and this person not only has antibodies to gliated peptides but they have antibodies to gliated itself and the celiac disease is much more serious.
So many times people with celiac disease can't even walk by a bakery without having a reaction so they'll breathe that in and it causes inflammation throughout their whole body.
Can it be healed?
But then who you ask? Some people say it could never be healed and I just said a little bit ago that if you do a Cyrex array 10 when you look at different food antibodies and you stay away from those foods, those antibodies to those foods will dissipate.
But there are some foods that just antibodies to certain foods that just don't tend to dissipate and gliated is one of those.
So can it be healed? I think God could heal anything but realistically can it be healed?
Not probably not. You're probably realistically looking at managing it the rest of your life.
What else should you do, though? And this would be this would answer what else should you do to the person who asked the Facebook question before if you have other food sensitivities?
Just stay away from that food is inadequate. So if you know you have antibodies to celiac, you know you have antibodies to gliated I mean.
And you have a diagnosed celiac disease, you absolutely should be doing a Cyrex array 10 to look for antibodies to other foods because there are gliated cross reactants.
So another test to do would be a Cyrex array 4 which tests specifically for all the cross reactants to gluten.
So a person can have antibodies to gluten and whether they have celiacs or not.
And they stayed away from gluten but they're eating foods that are cross reactant to group gluten.
So they can't figure out why they're not getting better. I'm staying away from gluten but every time they eat those foods that are cross reactants to gluten that they also have antibodies against they're causing more inflammation.
Which stems back to a basic understanding of immunology is that you can't be stimulating an immune system when you have antibodies particularly antibodies to self tissue.
So with celiac you have antibodies to self tissue. So every time you're going to cause inflammation of the gut you're going to damage your gut border.
But same thing goes if you have antibodies to other tissue like in the question of Hashimoto's or diagnosed with Hashimoto's you have antibodies to your thyroid gland.
Every time you cause inflammation due to whatever but certainly one of the most common ways that we cause daily inflammation is through our diet.
So if we're eating foods that we have antibodies against you're causing inflammation of the gut and systemically and you're going to destroy that which you have antibodies against whether it's your gut wall and celiac disease or whether it's your your thyroid gland
or whether it's you know you have really a lot of arthritis and you're damaging your your joy capsule cells. If you have MS you're going to be damaging mild and cheap cells.
So every time you cause inflammation in your body you're going to damage and destroy that which you have antibodies against person.
If it's self antibodies you're going to be destroying self tissue. So very important to find hidden sources of inflammation and the most common hidden source of inflammation are food that you're eating.
So if you're eating foods that you're inadvertently causing inflammation of the gut and you might not even have symptoms but you're causing inflammation throughout your whole body.
And this is the misdiagnosed or mismanaged part of autoimmune disorders.
So managing autoimmune disorders is first of all diagnostic and so I have an autoimmune disease and now I have to find my triggers that are stimulated by immune reaction.
It could be supplements I'm taking it could be chronic infections that I'm dealing with could be foods that I'm eating. So if you want a lot more deeper dive of that you can join my chronic disease and autoimmune course it's 50 bucks and you can start going through a whole mess of videos and really do a deep dive of fighting your triggers knowing what labs to run.
I'll give you a lot of different information in there and just have a whole bunch of videos in that course that will help you walk through that path.